GOOD AFTERNOON -- HOLIDAYS THANK
YOU FOR STAYING [inaudible]
SAME HERE.
ON AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE.
FORWARD AS BEST AS WE CAN WITH
THE AGENDA [inaudible]
OF WE'RE GOING TO HOLD OFF.
ROLL CALL WE WE PRESENT. TO THE
LOCAL.
SENATOR ALSO.
SENATOR NELSON SENATOR UMBERG.
SO WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO IS
TAKE OF FIRST THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR.
OF WE'RE GOING TO SKIP ONE UNTIL
SENATOR.
NIELSEN COMES.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE ON VOTE.
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO WE'LL HAVE A VOTE ON ISSUE
NUMBER.
TWO WE PLEASE CALL.
SENATOR DRAWS YES CENTER NIELSEN
[inaudible]
BETTER AMBER.
OKAY NOW OF WILL HAVE A VOTE ON
ISSUES. THREE TO FIVE THIS CALL
THE ROLL SENATOR DORADO BY.
SENATOR NELSON.
OKAY WILL COME BACK [inaudible]
TO NUMBER [inaudible]
ONE NIELSEN.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO ISSUE NUMBER.
SIX THE COMMISSION ON THE STATUS
OF WOMEN AND GIRLS PLEASE COME
FORWARD
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME STEP
MEANS A ONE WITH THE COMMISSION
ON THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS
WE HAVE OUR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
KENDRA HARRIS HERE AS WELL.
THANKFUL TO BE HERE TO BE ON THE
AGENDA THANKFUL TO YOU AND YOUR
STAFF AND WERE AVAILABLE YEAH
ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY I WAS -- SOME OF BRIDGES
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
CAROLINE FROM LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD TO THE THIS PC
PIZZA AUGMENT THE COMMISSION
STOPPING [inaudible]
OKAY.
FINANCE.
WAS ONE FROM THE FINANCE.
WE JUST RECENTLY RECEIVED THE
ANALYSIS BY THE AUGMENTATION
PORTION ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SO OF IT
THIS TIME WE WE ONLY SUPPORT THE
MITCHELL PROPOSAL.
WE'RE WORKING WITH STAFF -- TO
FURTHER ANALYZE [inaudible]
YOUR AUGMENTATION [inaudible]
OKAY.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
YOU WANT TO READ THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION THAT
[inaudible]
SELECT.
OKAY CALDERON SENATOR DRAW
THOUGH I UNDER NIELSEN.
SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU ALL IT WAS EASY.
OKAY NOT NEXT IS ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN THE FAIRVIEW DEVELOPMENT
CENTER [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR IN
EASTERN BILLS OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES ALONG WITH
MY COLLEAGUES.
JIM MARTIN IS REPRESENTING THAT
SOME MANAGEMENT BRANCH FOR TGS
TODAY.
APARTMENTS REQUESTING TWO POINT
TWO MILLION IN ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO COMPLETE THE SITE
EVALUATION PORTION.
THAT'S PART OF THE LARGER
DISPOSITION PROCESS OF VIEW
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER LOCATED IN
COSTA MESA CALIFORNIA.
THE STAFF REPORT ACCURATELY
DEPICTS THE SITE IS -- ON
APPROXIMATELY HUNDRED TEN ACRES
HUNDRED SIXTEEN BUILDINGS THIS
FIRST STEP IS REALLY JUST TO
ANALYZE THE CHARACTERISTICS OF
THE SITE SO THAT WE CAN KIND OF
DETERMINE POTENTIAL FUTURE USES
AND WORK ON THAT PROCESS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED JUST AS WE
DID WITH SOME -- SO.
REPORTER QUEST TO GET EVERYTHING
GOING.
AND START.
THE PROCESS OF ACTUALLY
DETERMINE WHAT'S ON SITE AND
WHAT THE OPTIONS.
BUT THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
LEO.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
ON SU SUPER FINANCE WE DEPART
BOZELL.
OKAY WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE [inaudible]
A MONTH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
STAFF.
JORDAN LINDSAY WITH THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIAN YORK UNITED THROUGH
POLICY CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE.
AS WELL TODAY I'M REPRESENT THE
LANHAM COALITION WHICH
REPRESENTS MORE THAN TWENTY
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE A KID REPRESENT THE THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOP THE DISABILITIES SERVED.
BY REGIONAL CENTERS -- AND
RECEIVING SERVICES GUARANTEED
UNDER THE LANHAM ACT.
I'M THE THREE REMAINING
AVAILABLE CENTERS THE FORTY
HEARD ONE JUST A FEW DAYS AGO
REGARDING SOME A DEVELOPMENT
CENTER.
AND THIS AND THEN REMAIN AT THE
HEART OF PORTER FILM.
REPRESENT THE LAST REAL
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE BELIEVE
CALIFORNIA HAS TO GET THIS RIGHT.
IN TO GET IT RIGHT AND WHAT IT
MEANS FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOP TO THAT'S
DISABILITIES MEANS THAT THESE
ASSETS ARE NOTCHES.
TO BE USED TO GENERATE FUNDS FOR
THE GENERAL FUND BUT INSTEAD ARE
USED TO CONTINUE TO BENEFIT
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPED TO DISABILITIES.
WE HAVE A THERE WAS A BUDGET
PROPOSAL LAST YEAR THERE IS A
BILL LAST YEAR AND A BILL THIS
YEAR AS WELL PROPOSING THAT
NGUYEN READ IN THE STATE
RECEIVES REVENUE FROM THESE
THREE ASSETS.
AT THAT REVENUE IS AS THESE
ASSETS USED TO BE.
LARGE INSTITUTIONAL HOUSING THAT
NOW IT FUNDS SMALL INTEGRATED
RESIDENTIAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR CALIFORNIANS WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPS A
DISABILITIES IT IS NO SECRET AND
AS A PRIORITY OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR. TO MAKE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MORE MORE
OPPORTUNE FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TO CALIFORNIA THIS IS A WAY TO
DO THAT ESPECIALLY FOR A
POPULATION WHO FACES THIS.
DISCRIMINATION AND EXTREME
CHALLENGES MOSTLY JUST BASED ON
AS A SIZE OF P. AND COME TO FIND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE DO NOT.
WANT TO GET INVOLVED WITH HOW
THE LOCALITIES OR WHAT SHOULD
HAPPEN TO THE PROPERTIES.
EXCEPT THAT IN THIS SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL AS WAS IN CINEMA
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER.
THERE WAS -- PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT THEY SHOULD
MAXIMIZE THE VALUE OF THE
PROPERTY THAT ANY YOU GUYS HAVE
YOUR DEVOTED ACTUAL S. TIME FOR
CINEMA. TO PRESENT MORE MONEY TO
THE TO CINEMA COUNTY TO TO TO
DEVELOP A PLANNING PROCESS BUT
THAT IT SHOULD MAXIMIZE THE
VALUE.
WE BELIEVE THE SAME SHOULD BE
DONE WITH FAIR USE THAT IT
SHOULD MAXIMIZE THE VALUE SO
THAT WHEN DISPOSITION DOES
HAPPEN.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT WE WOULD
WANT TO SEE DISPOSITION HAPPEN
WHETHER THAT'S A SAILOR LEASE.
THAT THE REVENUE CAN THEN BE
GENERATED INTO WHAT WE HAVE
PROPOSES A CULT AN INTEGRATED
COMMUNITY HOUSING FUND.
AT THEHOUSING COMMITTEE
DEPARTMENT HOUSING COMMITTEE
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS.
MMHM DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TO
CREATE NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
[inaudible]
ALSO LASTLY.
WE DO QUOTE COVER NEWSOME WHEN
HE WAS ASKED SPECIFICALLY ABOUT.
THE REVENUE THAT COULD BE
GENERATED FROM THESE ASSETS
QUOTE WE MARK THAT IS ONE OF THE
GREAT LOST OPPORTUNITIES IF WE
DIDN'T DO THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO.
IN ORANGE COUNTY THERE ARE THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION PEOPLE AND
RIGHT NOW THERE ARE THREE POINT
THREE MILLION IDEAS AS TO WHAT
SHOULD BE DONE WITH.
SO HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
DETERMINE WHAT WHICH OF THOSE
USES ARE GOING TO BE ANALYZED NO
JUDGE CARTER HAS.
SOME IDEAS THE COUNTY HAS SOME
IDEAS.
LEGISLATORS PROPOSALS.
SO IT'S AN EXCELLENT POINT
SENATOR -- THERE ARE CERTAINLY
LOTS OF IDEAS AND CERTAINLY NOT
THE POTENTIAL USES THE ASK
BEFORE YOU TODAY IS JUST.
TO ANALYZE THE SITE.
SO YOU KNOW THIS IS VERY SIMILAR
ITS FIRST STEP THAT WE TOOK WITH
CINNAMON WHERE BEFORE YOU CAN
HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT'S
POSSIBLE YOU HAVE TO KNOW ABOUT.
IT.
SO WHAT'S GOOD ABOUT THE SITE
WHAT IS THE CONDITION THE
BUILDINGS WHERE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT ARE THE
HAZARDS ONE OF THE PROBLEMS I
MEAN WOMEN.
AND SOME IS ACTUALLY GREAT CASE
STUDY IN THE THINGS WE FOUND THE
WAY TO DECIDE ASSESSMENT THAT
HELP INFORM.
COLLABORATIVE DISCUSSION WITH
ALL THE STATE IN THE REGION
ABOUT WHAT IS WHAT.
SO THIS FIRST STEP IS REALLY
DETERMINE WHAT.
CURRENT SITE CONDITIONS ARE
WHICH WOULD.
FORM THAT YOU TO DISCUSS ABOUT
WHAT.
BUT DON'T YOU NEED TO KNOW WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT WHATEVER EXIST
RIGHT NOW WHAT MAKES THIS IN THE
FUTURE DON'T YOU NEED TO TO KIND
OF KNOW WHAT PEOPLE ARE THINKING
ABOUT WHAT MAY EXIST IN THE
FUTURE TO SEE WHETHER OR NOT.
FOR EXAMPLE THE THE SOIL --
BUILDING THAT KIND OF THING.
YES I DON'T THINK I DON'T THINK
IT I THINK WE'RE SAYING THIS.
OKAY SAME THING I MEAN PART PART
OF THE INITIAL SITE ASSESSMENT
WOULD BE THINGS LIKE A
REASONABLE DEAL -- GEOLOGICAL
SURVEY TERM IN NOW IF THERE'S A
CLEAN UP NEEDS ON THE SITE OR
WATER ISSUES ON THE SITE OR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ALL THAT IS
KIND OF THE BASE LEVEL
INFORMATION YOU NEED TO HAVE. TO
REALLY HAVE A HEARTY DISCUSSION
ABOUT IT COULD WE DO WHAT SIZE
BUILDINGS COULD BE THERE WHAT
KIND OF INFRASTRUCTURE IT WILL
BE NEEDED TO SUPPORT THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY.
ON THE CAMPUS.
ALL OF THE SITE ASSESSMENT WORK.
WORMS THAT THAT SUCH.
SO ARE YOU INVOLVING THE
COMMUNITY IN.
A DEVELOPING THE PLAN FOR THE
SITE ASSESSMENT.
NOW ONCE ONCE.
MUCH LIKE ANDERS SAID ONCE WE
CAN GET OUR GET A HANDLE ON
EXACTLY WHAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
LOOKS LIKE THE SOIL THAT WASTE
WATER WHAT HAVE YOU.
WILL BE A LARGER STAKEHOLDER
CONVERSATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE LOCALS AND
ANY STATE ENTITIES SO THE SITE
ASSESSMENTS I MEAN IT'S PRETTY
STANDARD PRACTICE RATES ARE
GONNA HAVE A TEAM GO AND ANALYZE
THE QUALITY OF THE BUILDINGS
STATUS BOTH BUILDINGS ANALYZE
UNDERGROUND INFRASTRUCTURE.
ALL THE RESOURCES THAT ARE ON
THIS ON THE CAMPUS LOOK FOR
POTENTIAL ISSUES OF GEOLOGY --
HAZARDOUS WASTE ALL THE GUY KIND
OF GIVE THE WHOLE LAY OF THE
LAND THE PICTURE OF WHAT THE
CAMPUS IS AND WHAT'S ON THEIR
DAY.
THOSE ACTIONS AND STEPS ARE
PRETTY STANDARD EYES.
BUT WE WILL BE BRINGING IN THE
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY AND MAKING
ALL PUBLICLY AVAILABLE TO START
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT.
OKAY SO WITH THE END OF THE DAY
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SAY YES WE CAN
BUILD A PRESCHOOL HERE.
YES WE CAN OR WE CANNOT BUILD A
PRESCHOOL OR WEEK.
BUILD A PRESCHOOL BUT THIS IS
THE KIND OF REMEDIATION THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED IS THAT RIGHT
RIGHT SO THE CENTURY SAYS AND
CAN GIVE YOU ALL THE DETAILS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DO YOU RESPOND TO THE PREVIOUS
GENTLEMAN'S -- CONCERNS AND THE
ISSUE OF MAXIMIZING THE VALUE
YEAH I THINK THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT WENT UP I KNOW IT
CAME UP THE LAST HEARING AND WE
DIDN'T REALLY GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS IT --
COUPLE THINGS ONE I KNOW THAT
THERE IS A PROPOSAL FOR YOU DOES
NOT INCLUDE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
POINT THIS IS JUST A ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND ASKED TO START THIS
WORK.
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
WAS APPROVED LAST WEEK BY THIS
COMMITTEE.
INCLUDED LANGUAGE THAT TALK
ABOUT MAXIMIZING VALUE IT ALSO
TALKED ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
THE RESIDENTS WERE WORK OR CARE
OR AND THAT.
THERE WAS -- A CLEAR FOCUS ON
THE INTENT OF THE LANGUAGE TO
FOCUS ON THE LONG.
SO BOTH OF THOSE PIECES WERE IN
THAT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS MISTER
NOT BROUGHT UP BUT WHAT I DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
IS POINTS REPAIR IN TERMS OF
WHAT HAPPENS LONG TERM WITH WITH
ANY REVENUE THAT WOULD BE
GENERATED FROM A PROCEEDS OF
SAILOR DITION.
THAT'S THAT'S REALLY IN YOUR
PERFUME TO DECIDE BECAUSE IT
WOULD ALL BE GOING TO THE
GENERAL FUND IN ALLOCATING
RESOURCES THE GENERAL FUND
[inaudible]
LEGISLATURE.
OKAY.
THAT.
MEANS THERE'S THE WHAT WE DO
WITH RIGHT OR THE IDEA OF THE
SUGGEST. TO MAXIMIZE THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE USE AND THIS IS
THE NUMBER.
SO FROM A PURELY PROCESS
STANDPOINT WERE IS THE YEAH
RIGHT WHERE IT STEP ONE WHERE
WHAT WE PRESENTED TO YOU LAST
WEEK WAS A RESULT STEPS LIKE --
ONE SO THIS ISN'T THE FIRST TIME
WILL BE SPEAKING WITH YOU ON
THIS TOPIC IT IS THE FIRST TIME
IT WILL BE THE LAST SUMMER
SPEAKING WITH YOU ON THIS TOPIC
WILL BE [inaudible]
ANYTHING.
NO WE DON'T HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE RESULT OF FOLLOWING THE
GENERAL PROCESS THE STAR
[inaudible]
OKAY.
GREAT.
SO DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOTION SANFORD EMENDATION A
REQUEST REQUESTED.
ON ROLE IN A DRUG.
I ENTERED INYO SPENT BY SENATOR
AMBER [inaudible]
SENATE.
YES WILL MOVE BACK TO ITEM.
ONE THIS IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE CONTROL
[inaudible]
AND THE THEIR MOST.
TO MOVE [inaudible]
ENTER DORADO.
THEN WE NEED TO DO.
YES BROTHER I SENATOR NIELSEN
SENATOR UMBERG [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
IT'S GOING.
TO ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible] NINE
EIGHT CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
[inaudible]
WELCOME BACK [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I AM BOUND CRAWFORD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL.
AND I'VE RIGHT -- KRISTIN MARK
ON TO WHO IS ON MY AT
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR AND IONIC
COULD VERY WHO IS MY DEPUTY
DIRECTOR.
AND YOU'VE ALL BEEN HANDED
PACKETS THAT -- AYE ANIMALS.
BRIEFLY GO OVER WITH YOU.
IN A FEW MINUTES.
AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THERE WERE CURRENTLY SCHEDULED
TO PRESENT CON CURRENTLY BEING
HERE AND THE ASSEMBLY SO.
I'M GONNA JUST READ THIS BECAUSE
WE THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO BE
IN TWO DIFFERENT PLACES AND WE
WANTED TO BE CONSISTENT.
AM IN OUR TESTIMONY.
REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S
REVISIONS TO OUR BUDGET.
TOM THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
IS PRIMARILY A GRANT MAKING
AGENCY WITH THE RESPONSIBILITY
TO ENSURE THE ACCESSIBILITY OF
OUR PROGRAMS TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
AM ACCESSIBILITY STATEWIDE IS
ACCOMPLISHED BY THE FOLLOWING
STAFF WORK -- TARGETED REGIONAL
OUTREACH WORKSHOPS COMMUNITY
MEETINGS WEBINARS M. MONITORING.
YEAH THE GRANT MANAGEMENT SYSTEM
THAT WE USE AT THAT CONTINUAL
EVALUATION THAT WE DO WITH OUR
EFFECTIVENESS IN THE FIELD
A CANELA JUDY.
COUNCIL APPROVAL PROCESS.
SEE A C. IS REQUESTING AN
ADDITIONAL POSITION AUTHORITY R
SIX POINT THREE POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT.
DISTRIBUTION OF OUR LOCAL AS AN
EXPENSE.
WE ARE GRANTING PROGRAMS.
SINCE HE AGENCIES DEVASTATING
CUTS OVER A DECADE AGO SEE A C.
AS BEEN FUNCTIONING ADDED
DEFICIT IN HUMAN RESOURCES.
PRESENTLY THE CHC HAS BEEN
OPERATING WITH A STAFF OF TWENTY
THREE POINT.
FIVE FTE POSITIONS ADMINISTERING
LOCAL ASSISTANCE TOTALING
FIFTEEN POINT NINE MILLION AND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDED
AN ADDITIONAL ON GOING TEN
MILLION THE CA SEE BUDGET.
IN THE FISCAL YEAR 200-019-2000
[inaudible]
TWENTY THIS AUGMENTS.
EQUATES TO A 60% INCREASE.
IN OUR GRANTING FUNCTIONS WITH
LOCAL ASSISTANT.
AT APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS.
WITHOUT ADDITIONAL POSITION OF
AUTHORITY IS C. A. C. WILL HAVE
ONLY TWENTY THREE POINT FIVE
POSITIONS TO IT MESSED MINISTER
THE TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
TO ILLUSTRATE THIS POINT IT'S
HELPFUL TO LOOK AT THE BUDGET
AND STAFFING IN 200-012-0002.
WHEN LOCAL ASSISTANCE WAS
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SIX MILLION
WITH FORTY FOUR POINT SEVEN F.
T.?
ALMOST DOUBLE THOSE POSITIONS.
WE HAVE A EVERY.
WORKFORCE AND ALICE'S.
AM.
AGENCIES BUDGET HAS
INCREMENTALLY INCREASED FROM.
ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO FIFTEEN
POINT. NINE NINE IN AN EFFORT TO
MOVE TOWARDS SERVING.
GEOGRAPHIC AND CULTURAL
DIVERSITY IN OUR STATE.
SEE A C. NOW ADMINISTERS
EIGHTEEN GRANT PROGRAMS.
SERVING APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
HUNDRED ARTS ORGANIZATION.
THESE EIGHT HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS REPRESENT A SMALL
FRACTION OF THE ELEVEN THOUSAND
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS IN THE EIGHT
ALMOST. SEVENTEEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE GRANTS WERE ADMINISTERED
THIS YEAR WITH CURRENT STAFF
ALREADY OVER CAPACITY.
AND NEED TO PASS ON EXCESS
REDUCED TO COMPLETE THE KEY
FUNCTIONS NECESSARY IN THE GRANT
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS AND PROVIDE
THE OUT REACH.
IT'S EXPECTED OF A STATE ARTS
AGENCY.
THE AGENCY HAS A LIMITED AMOUNT
OF APPROVED PHYSICIANS AND AN
INCREASED BUDGETARY AUTHORITY.
WHICH IS RESULT IN AN INCREASE
TECHNICAL ANALYTICAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE NEEDS TO SUPPORT
THE GROWTH OF THE AGENCY'S
PROGRAM.
WE'VE PROVIDED YOU WITH PACKETS
OF INFORMATION.
AT THE MY DEPUTY IS GOING TO GO
OVER WITH YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SO YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU A FEW SLIDES FROM.
OUR SIDE.
AND I WANT TO JUST EXPLAIN TO
YOU -- THE GOVERNOR MAY REVISE
REVISION INCLUDED AN INITIAL AN
ADDITIONAL TEN MILLION THE
FINANCE LETTER INDICATES.
AT C. C. WILL DISTRIBUTE FIVE
MILLION TO THE ARMENIAN AMERICAN
MUSEUM. FIVE MILLION TO THE LOS
ANGELES MUSEUM OF THE WHOLE. 5%
PROVISION IS RESTRICTED TO THE
TEN MILLION THAT WAS IN OUR
LOCAL ASSISTANCE PROJECT WHICH
YOU SEE HERE IS OUR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE PERSONS ARE
AUTHORIZED POSITIONS JUST TO TRY
TO INTEGRATE TO YOU.
THE DIFFERENCE WITH OUR GROWTH
[inaudible]
THE YELLOW.
OUR IS OUR BUDGET INCREASES AND
AT THE BOTTOM M. IS THE STAFF
BEING BASED VERY INCREMENTAL TO
THE NUMBER TO THE AMOUNT OF
BUDGET SEARCH THE FLAT LINE.
WE REALLY HAVEN'T SEEN ANY MAJOR
INCREASES IN OUR BUDGET THIS
DOES INCLUDE THOSE -- ONE TIME
FUNDS AS WELL AS PERMANENT
FUNDING OVER THE YEARS.
THAT'S WHAT THAT FIRST SLIDE
SHOWS IF YOU TURN IT OVER.
WE HAVE A WORK.
LOAD MEASURES OVER FISCAL YEAR.
SO YOU'LL SEE THAT ACROSS TIME
HERE ARE SOME MAJOR KEY
FUNCTIONS OF OUR AGENCY WE DO
GRANT PROGRAMS.
OR THE BLUE IS THE NUMBER OF
GRANT.
PROGRAMS THAT -- WE THAT WE ARE
MANAGING THE ORANGE IS THE GRANT
APPLICATIONS RECEIVED.
THEY RAISE THE GRANT
APPLICATIONS APPROVED IT WHICH
MEANS WE HAVE TO MAKE THOSE
UNDER CONTRACT -- WE HAVE PANELS.
AN OLD LINE THAT THROUGHOUT ALL
OF OURS.
I'M NUMBER OF PANELISTS SO WE
HAVE AN INCREASING NUMBER OF
PANELISTS THAT WE WORK WITH.
ARE JUST ORDERS PROCESSES THE
GREEN AND DOCTORS PROCESSES A
LARGE BLUE.
AND YOU'LL SEE OVER IME THAT WE
CONTINUE TO EXPAND IN THE WORK
TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE WORK LOAD.
BUT IF IF YOU LOOK AT THE THE
DIFFERENT BARS.
THE BLUE BAR REPRESENTS ONE
INDIVIDUAL THAT IS WORKING ALL
OF THOSE PROGRAMS ALL OF THOSE --
AT GRANT PROGRAMS AND THEN THE
GREEN BAR REPRESENTS A PART TIME
PERSON IN THE GRAY IN THE YELLOW
IS ACTUALLY ONE PERSON MANAGING
ALL OF THAT.
INCREASE OVER TIME.
SO MY HOPE THAT THIS.
KIND OF ROUNDED AND GIVE YOU
SOME CONTEXT INTO THE WORK.
RIGHT NOW MY WE NEED.
TO IN ADDITION TO WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN PUT IT HERE THERE IS A TEST
CASE OF BREACH OF POSITIONS THAT
WE WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL THIS TIME THE WE ARE I
THINK STILL WAITING ON THE
DETAILS FROM THE EAST
[inaudible]
I KNOW.
REMAINING IN A FINANCE.
WELL HERE I MANY YEARS THIS
[inaudible]
ARTISTIC STATE [inaudible]
COUNSEL.
HAD ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT CLEARLY KEPT.
THE DOORS OF WHATEVER THEY WERE
ABLE TO GRANT.
PROVIDE.
WAS ACHIEVED THROUGH A CHECK OFF.
SOMETIMES THEY WOULD PICK UP THE
GRANT.
AND THEY DID A LICENSE PLATE.
WELL THEY WERE VALUE TO KEEP
THEMSELVES ALIVE.
AND THEN WE RESURRECTED.
AND THIS WILL CONTINUE THE
ASCENT I WOULDN'T MOVE THE OKAY.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE
AS REQUEST COMMENT.
YES MADAM.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DAVID JONES OF
HAVE THE CITY OF GLENDALE
OBVIOUSLY VERY STRONG IN SUPPORT
OF THE ARMENIAN MUSEUM.
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE ARTS
COUNCIL IT'S BEEN DECIMATED OVER
THE YEARS.
SO WE'RE VERY ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT
SUPPORTING ARTS AND SPECIFICALLY
THE ARMY MUSEUM WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT CITIZENS BLUNDELL
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR AND RUNOFF THANK YOU
HI MY NAME'S JULIE BECKER AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CALFORNIA
ARTS ADVOCATES -- WE'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR INCREASED UNDING
FOR THE ARTS IN THE CREATIVE
SECTORS IN CALIFORNIA.
WE LOVE TO SEE THE INCREASE
CONTINUE TO BUILD TO THE ARTS
COUNCIL CAN SERVE AND PROVIDE
ACCESS TO GRANTS IN SUPPORT OF
THE ARTS AND CREATIVE CONNIE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS.
ALTHOUGH WE DO NOT OPPOSE
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S LINE ITEMS
FOR THE HOLOCAUST AND ARMENIAN
MUSEUMS AND ARE IN SUPPORT OF
ALL FUNDING THAT GOES TOWARDS
THE ARTS WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE APPROPRIATION GOING THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCILS
BUDGET.
CSE DOES NOT FUND CAPITAL OUTLAY
BUT IT IS ACTUALLY FOR BITTEN
UNDER THE CURRENT REGULATIONS.
IN ADDITION THIS PROPOSED PASSED
THROUGH ALLOCATION IS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE CA SEES
MISSION CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
IS THE GRANT MAKING ARM OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THEIR MODEL IS TO PROVIDE
FOR A FAIR AND COMPETITIVE GRANT
PROCESS THAT IT HERE'S TO THE
HIGHESTSTANDARDS.
THE C. A. C. FUNDS COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AT LEVELS.
DISSIPATED BY THESE TWO LARGE
APPROPRIATIONS.
WE RESERVE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
SUBMIT THAT THIS FUNDING WILL BE
MORE PROPERLY PASSED THROUGH TO
THESE MUSEUMS FREE OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUSEUM GRANT PROGRAM
CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
WHEN GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN STATE
SIGN AB.
FORTY TWO CALIFORNIA MUSEUM
GRANT PROGRAM IS AN OBJECTIVELY
BETTER MECHANISM FOR EXECUTING
THIS.
SHOULD THE SHOULD THE
LEGISLATIVE VOTE TO DO SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I DO
I DO WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT THAT
I THINK THAT IT'S A IT'S GREAT
TO BE GIVING FUNDING TO THE
ARMENIAN AMERICAN MUSEUM.
I THINK THAT'S A VERY AND ALSO
THE MUSEUM OF THE HOLOCAUST IN
PARTICULAR I'M CONCERNED I MEAN
I'M I'M HAPPY TO SEE THE
ARMENIAN AMERICAN MUSEUM BECAUSE
AS A LIGHT.
A NUMBER OF OUR ARMENIANS NOT
ONLY IN MY DISTRICT BUT IN IN
THE IN THE BROADER LA COUNTY
AREA SO [inaudible]
IS [inaudible]
ONE AND FORCE.
NUMBER SUPPORT THIS BUT I WOULD
HAVE STAFF TO IMMEDIATELY NET
LET THE CHAIR OF ST
APPROPRIATIONS NOW BUT I SUPPORT
IT SO.
OKAY WE WROTE.
SENATOR DRAWS A I SENATOR NELSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
OKAY.
ITEM NUMBER ISSUE NUMBER.
NINE DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS.
YES -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BETH MISSIONS BEING EMPTY FOR
VETERANS HOME OPERATIONS FOR
CALVET.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT THIS WITH TO YOU AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
I'M HERE TODAY TO DISCUSS THE
FOR THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IN
FRONT OF YOU ALIGNING THE
MILITARY VETERANS COPE WITH
CALVET.
WITH CALVET BUDGET STRUCTURE --
AS YOU MAY RECALL THIS ISSUE
CAME UP DURING THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE IS AUDIT OF
CALVET LEASES AT CERTAIN
VETERANS HOMES.
ON THE AUDITOR REFERENCE.
THE IN ITS IN THEIR FINAL REPORT
A SECTION OF CODE OF MILITARY
VETERANS CODE THAT DATED CAL
THAT SHOULD BE RETAINING AN
AUGMENTING.
HOMES BUDGETS WITH REVENUES THAT
ARE COLLECTED THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR -- OR ACTUALLY IT WAS THAT
IT WASN'T SO MUCH THAT WE SHOULD
BE WAS THAT THE LANGUAGE
INDICATED THAT THE MILITARY
VETERANS CODE LANGUAGE -- SAID
THAT WE SHOULD BE.
AND THAT WE HAD NOT BEEN
RETAINING WHAT WE'VE BEEN
COLLECTING.
IT IS TRUE THAT WE HAVE NOT BEEN
RETAINING IT AND THAT'S BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN OPERATING IN
ACCORDANCE WITH OUR BUDGET
STRUCTURE THAT WAS ESTABLISHED.
BY THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT A DECADE AGO --
THAT STRUCTURE PROVIDES CALVET
FULL FUNDING OF THE GENERAL FUND
AT THE START OF EACH FISCAL YEAR
FOR OUR ONGOING REGULAR
OPERATIONS.
AND THEN SO THAT WE CAN OPERATE
AS AROUND THE CLOCK HEALTHCARE
ORGANIZATION AND THEN THAT THEN
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR WE COLLECT
REVENUES.
FROM A VARIETY OF SOURCES AND
RETURN THAT BACK TO THE GENERAL
FUND. TO OFFSET WHAT WE WERE
PROVIDED ON THE FRONT -- THE
AUDITOR INDICATED IN THEIR FINAL
REPORT THAT THE STATE SHOULD IN
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER ONLINE TO
CODE WITH.
AND THESE CHANGES SIR TO DO THAT.
BECAUSE THE FUNDING STRUCTURE I
DESCRIBED IT WAS ESTABLISHED
FORMALLY TO THE STATE BUDGET
PROCESS -- RETAINING THE FUNDS
TO AUGMENT OUR HOMES BUDGETS
WOULD.
BE A CALL WOULD BE A PRACTICE
THAT'S OUTSIDE OF THAT -- IT BY
WHAT WE BELIEVE THE INTENT WAS
AT THE TIME THAT THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED.
SO THEREFORE INSTEAD WHAT YOU
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU.
ALEXA CORRECT THE OUTDATED COACH
CODE LANGUAGE TO BRING THE TWO
INTO ALIGNMENT -- IT'S SORT OF
AN OVERVIEW FOR YOU I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT NOT.
ANIMAL YOU KNOW CONCERNS.
YES.
AND I AM -- CONVEYED TO CALVET
IT'S QUESTIONS BETWEEN THE TAP
PROGRAM.
NOW THE FOR THOSE TO SOMEBODY
ELSE FROM CALVET BUT I AM
INTERESTED TO PASS ALONG I WILL
BE HAPPY TO TRANSITION.
OKAY THIS IS PROGRAM -- I MOVE
THE MEASURE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
PUBLIC [inaudible]
COMMENT [inaudible]
NO.
OKAY SEE.
NINE WE HAVE LOCAL.
ENERGY BROTHER I ENERGY NIELSEN.
SENATOR ALBERT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE DON'T HAVE [inaudible] TO
SOMEONE.
OKAY -- ITEM TEN SECRETARY OF
STATE VOTING SYSTEMS REPLACEMENT
FOR COUNTIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF
SUSAN LAPSLEY W. SECTORS STATE.
SURGERIES STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M WE ARE PROPOSING EIGHTY
SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO IN ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND. TO COVER THE COST
REPLACEMENT OF VOTING SYSTEMS
WHICH INCLUDES.
TABULATION EQUIPMENT ACCESSIBLE.
APPOINTMENTS ELECTION MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM SOFTWARE HARDWARE --
ELECTRONIC BOOKS AND ON DEMAND --
PRINTERS.
AS YOU MAY RECALL WE WERE HERE
LAST NIGHT LAST YEAR AND IT MADE
A REQUEST FOR FUNDING FOR THE
REPLACEMENT OF OWNING SYSTEM SAY.
THAT TIME WE DISCUSSED THIS
STATE OF AFFAIRS OR WE WERE AS
FAR AS THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
AND THE DESPERATE NEED.
FOR IMPROVEMENT AND UPGRADE OF
THOSE VOTING SYSTEMS AND AT THE
TIME.
YOU'LL ALL GENEROUSLY
APPROPRIATED HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
IT HAD A FIFTY FIFTY MATCH
ATTACHED TO IT THIS IS TO
SUPPLEMENT THAT REQUEST AND TO
MODIFY THE B. AND MATCH FROM A
FIFTY FIFTY REQUEST TO A SEVENTY
FIVE TWENTY FIVE THE FEEDBACK
THAT WE'VE GOT FROM COUNTIES WAS
THAT THE FIFTY FIFTY MATCH
ESPECIALLY FOR THE SMALL COUNTY.
AS WAS AND DIFFICULT FOR THEM
AND NOT IN LINE WITH PAST
PRACTICES FOR FUNDING BOTH THE
FEDERAL FUNDING AND THE STATE
BUILDING MODERNIZATION BOARD
FUNDING.
WERE ADDISON A FIVE TWENTY FIVE
MATCH THIS REQUEST BRINGS.
THIS FUNDING THAT AND IT
AUGMENTS IT TO BRING IN LINE
WITH THAT.
MATCHING CRITERIA.
I AM OPEN TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON THIS.
SO WE JUST NOTED AS WAS ALREADY
SEATED BY THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR
PROVIDED A HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS.
NONE OF THOSE FUNDS HAVE YET
BEEN RECEIVED BY THE CHINESE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE NOTE SO
THERE'S A PRETTY.
I INVOLVED PROCESS -- THAT GOES
INTO.
THE COUNTY IS.
MOVING THE FUNDING RECEIVING THE
GRANTS AND SO FORTH SO WE JUST --
POSED A FEW QUESTIONS FOR YOU TO
CONSIDER THAT WE ARE RELATED TO
STOP.
OVER THE WEEKEND INCLUDING --
WHAT DELAYS OF ANY THERE MIGHT
BE IN GETTING THESE FUNDS INTO
COUNTIES AND WHETHER OR NOT
CHINESE WOULD -- REALISTICALLY
BE ABLE TO USE THE SPONSOR FOR
DISAPPOINTMENT FOR THE UPCOMING
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION.
ON AND ONE SORT OF THAT PICTURE
BECAME CLEAR.
ARE HOW MIGHT THESE FUNDS BE
BEST UTILIZED TO SHORE UP
ELECTIONS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
AND AT THE STATE LEVEL. FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION GIVEN.
THE PROCESSING DELAYS IN GETTING
THESE BONDS.
PLEASE RESPOND I WOULD BE HAPPY.
TO I AM THE PROCESS WITH
APPROPRIATION -- THERE WERE
DELAYS AND THAT WAS IN LARGE
PART BECAUSE OUR AGENCY WAS
GOING TO THE PROCESS OF DISCOUNT
AND IMITATION WHICH HAS --
BROUGHT AND A SLOWDOWN TO EVERY
ASPECT OF ALL OF OUR OFFICE IN --
GENERATING CONTRACTS
IMPLEMENTING CONTRACTS SAID THE
WHOLE SPECTRUM OF IT.
THESE A REIMBURSEMENT BASED
CONTRACTS SO THEY BE THE
COUNTIES GET CONTRACTS THEY GO
THROUGH THEIR BOARD PROCESS AND
THEN THE IMPACT BUT SO. FOR US
TO GET HIM OUT THE DOOR WAS SLOW
BECAUSE OF OUR FISCAL
IMPLEMENTATION.
THEN ONCE WE GET INTO THE COUNTY
IS THE COUNTIES THEN HAVE TO GO
TO THEIR BOARDS AND GET THEIR
APPROVAL AND AND GO THROUGH
THEIR MACHEN ASIANS AND THEN
THEY SEND IT BACK TO US.
SO WE DO HAVE I BELIEVE -- FIFTY
OF THE FIFTY EIGHT M. CONTRACTS
RETURNS.
WE HAVE BEEN RECEIVING REQUESTS
FOR REIMBURSEMENT FROM THIS
COUNTY IS AN REQUEST THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE IN APPROVED BY OFFICE
OUR OFFICE.
THOSE THEN GO TO THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE WHICH THEN
HAS THEIR OWN PROCESS FOR
ACTUALLY USING THOSE.
AND SO WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
WE'VE BEEN RECEIVING LOTS OF
REQUESTS FROM COUNTERED AT
QUESTIONS FROM COUNTIES ABOUT.
HOW THE REQUESTED?
THEY'VE BEEN VOICING THEIR
CONCERN ABOUT THE FIFTY FIFTY
MATCH IN THERE.
THE RETICENCE ON SOME OTHER
BOARDS TO ENTER INTO CONTRACTS
BECAUSE IT'S JUST NOT ENOUGH
MONEY SO I THINK.
THIS ALLOCATION AND THE CHANGE
OF THE MATCH FOR A FIFTY FIFTY
TO SEVENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE WILL
REALLY SPEED UP.
IT SOUNDS LIKE IT WILL BE THE OR
CERTAIN COUNTIES.
WHOSE MAJOR PROBLEM WAS
FINANCIAL.
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY EXPLAIN --
YOU WILL SPEED UP WITH THE
COUNTY THROUGH DIDN'T HAVE
FINANCIAL ISSUE AS FAR AS BEING
ABLE.
TO MAP.
OR FISCAL ALL THAT THE SLOW DOWN
BECAUSE OF THIS GAL.
WELL THE NON.
THE COUNTIES THAT DIDN'T HAVE
THE FINANCING TO BE ABLE TO DO.
THE MEADOW THERE'S A COUPLE
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS IN THIS SO
THERE'S THAT IT BY TAKING UP A
FIFTY FIFTY MATCH TO A SEVENTY
FIVE TWENTY FIVE MATCH IT
REDUCES THE AMOUNT OF THAT THEY
HAVE TO COME UP.
AS A MATTER.
THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER PROVISION
IN THIS THAT FOR THOSE COUNTIES
THAT HAVE FIFTY OR FEWER
PRECINCTS.
THERE'S NO MATCH SO THAT I THINK
GOES A LONG WAYS FOR THOSE
SMALLER COUNTIES THAT REALLY ARE
GOING TO HAVE DIFFICULTY IN
COMING UP WITH ANY ANY MATCH.
I'M AS I SAID OUR GOOD WE DO
HAVE CONTRACTS BACK FOR FIFTY OF
THEM -- AND HAVING THOSE IN
PLACE NOW MAKES THE
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS.
AND MUCH.
NOW IS IT CAN BE DONE MORE
EXPEDITED. FIFTY EIGHT OF THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
YOU HAVE A CONTRACT.
IT JUST HAPPENED NOW REQUESTED
REIMBURSEMENTS.
WE HAVE THEIR CONTRACTORS IN DID
IT WITHOUT.
ON THE BASIS OF THE MATCH IT NOT
ON THE BASIS OF THE SEVENTY FIVE
TWENTY WRAPPED.
SO WHY DO YOU NEED. SEVENTY FIVE
TWENTY FIVE YEAH [inaudible]
ALREADY AGREED.
ITS IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT THE
FIFTY FIFTY IN ALLOCATION THE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR WAS IN A
SUFFICIENT MATH IT WASN'T
SUFFICIENT FUNDING FOR THEM.
AND WHAT WAS NEEDED FOR THE
WHOLE ELECTION INFRASTRUCTURE
THE VOTING SYSTEMS OF TELL
TABULATION ELECTRONIC BOOKS
ABOUT ON IT.
SO THIS MAKES A CONSISTENT WITH
OUR PREVIOUS REQUEST -- FOR THE
FULL AMOUNT OF AT A 7525% MATCH
[inaudible]
THE WE LIKE I SAID WE DID HEAR
MANY COMPLAINTS FROM COUNTY IS
THAT.
GOSH THIS FIFTY FIFTY MATCH
WASN'T ENOUGH AND IT WITH ITS
WAS REALLY DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
DO -- THEY NOT THEY ENTERED INTO
IT BUT KNOWING AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT BUT THEY THINK THAT THEY
HAD ADVOCATED BOTH TO THEIR MORE
SUPERVISORS TO OUR OFFICE AND
OTHERS THAT JUST TO GET THE V.
M..
MATCH CHANGED IN IT AND
INCREASED BE THAT THE FUNDING
AMOUNT TO BE SPENT WITH.
AGAIN WHAT THE WAY WITH AN AXE.
IT IF I MAY I MEAN I I THINK
SORT OF THE QUESTION HERE
LEGISLATURE IS IS A POLICY
CHOICE BUT THE LEGISLATURE
CHOOSE TO GIVEN THAT MOST
COUNTIES OF ALREADY OPTED TO
OPERATOR IN THE PROCESS OF
UPGRADING THEIR VOTING SYSTEMS
DO THEY WANT TO INCREASE THE
SUBSIDY TO WHAT.
I HAVE.
ON OUT.
THERE IS A STATE RATIONALE IN
TERMS OF AN INTEREST IN TERMS OF
TO KERN IT'S A LITTLE ACTION SO
IT'S NOT NOT.
INCONSISTENT FOR THE STATE TO DO
SO -- BUT IF IT DOES.
THE IT DOES NOT IT AT AT AT
LEAST THE INFORMATION WE'VE
GOTTEN SO FAR AND IT'S ONLY BEEN
A COUPLE DAYS IN OUR HANDS --
SEEM THAT IT'S NECESSARILY GOING
TO IMPORT A LOT OF ANI'S CHOICES
THAN WHAT THEY DO FOR THE
UPCOMING ELECTION.
AND I'M SORRY I WILL DISAGREE
WITH THAT -- I THINK THAT IT IS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING [inaudible]
IT.
ALLOWS THEM TO DO MORE IN
ANTICIPATION OF TWENTY TWENTY I
THINK.
THE MAJORITY OF THEM ALREADY AS
SO.
WE'VE THE SECRETARY HAD
INITIATED THE PROCESS TO
DECERTIFY VOTING SYSTEMS THAT
AREN'T.
TESTED AND CERTIFIED TO OUR
LATEST STANDARDS.
AND WE BEGAN THAT PROCESS IN
FEBRUARY AND OF ALL THE COUNTIES
HAVE BEEN MOVING FORWARD KNOWING
THAT THAT GOES INTO A FACT AND
IN ANTICIPATION OF THE MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION
[inaudible]
SO.
LEADING UP TO THAT MANY OF THE
COUNTIES WERE ALREADY ON THEIR
WAY TO GETTING NEW VOTING
SYSTEMS.
THIS MONEY GOES TO OF LARGER.
PIECE OF THE ELECTION PIES SO WE
HAVE.
WE HAVE OUTDATED INFRASTRUCTURE
THE THEY CAN NOW PURCHASE -- OUT
BALLOT ON MAN PRINTERS THEY CAN
NOW PURCHASE -- ELECTION
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS THAT CAN NOW
PRINT AND PURCHASE.
VOTER VOTE TABULATION THEY CAN
VOTE IT'S IT'S MORE THAN JUST
THOSE VOTING SYSTEM SO I THINK
WITH THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO SHORE UP.
MORE THAN THEY HAD THOUGHT THAT
THEY COULD DO IN ADVANCE OF
TWENTY TWENTY I THINK THAT.
THE MATCH.
IT WAS A FIFTY FIFTY MATCH
THAT'S A BIG CAPITAL OUTLAY FOR
THEM SO INSTEAD OF BUYING.
YOU KNOW A FULL PIE THEY BOUGHT
HALF OF HI WITH THIS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THEY CAN BY THREE
QUARTERS OF A HIGH.
AND SHORT THEMSELVES UP IN AND
BE BETTER PREPARED.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA IN
JEOPARDY OF HAVING THE CERTIFIED.
VOTING APPARATUS BUT TWENTY
MARCH [inaudible]
TWENTY TWENTY PRIMARY.
SO.
AS WE HAVE THIS PART OF THE
DECERTIFICATION -- WE A AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE'S SOME
CHALLENGES THAT GO INTO
PROCURING A VOTING SYSTEM AND
AND THE NATURAL PROCUREMENT
PROCESS.
WE ALOUD'S COUNTIES TO REQUEST
TO OUR OFFICE A CONDITIONAL USE
OF IT OUR EXTENDED.
CONDITIONAL USE -- APPROVAL SO
OF THAT OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES RECEIVES -- THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THIRTY THANK
YOU THIRTEEN REQUEST FOR
EXTENSION.
OF THOSE NINE WERE -- SORT OF
BACK UP STAYS SAID.
YOU KNOW SURGERY STATE WE'RE
GONNA PUT THE SAND WHERE WE'VE
START THE PROCUREMENT PROCESS
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH
GETTING A NEW VOTING SYSTEM --
BUT WE WANT TO PUT THIS IN JUST
IN CASE BECAUSE SOMETIMES THINGS
HAPPEN.
IT'S ARE RESPONSIVE THAT THERE'S
WIND UP NOT GETTING AN UP -- IT
INDIVIDUAL COMPANIES RESPONDING
THAT KIND OF THING SO WE'RE
GONNA BUT THE SENSE YOU.
TO AND JUST AS A PLACEHOLDER.
THE REMAINING FOUR TWO OF THEM
HAVE PLANS TO IMPLEMENT IN A
PHASED APPROACH SO THEY A..
M. WOULD DO PART OF THE NEW
VOTING SYSTEM IN THE PRIMARY
BECAUSE AGAIN THE MEMORIES BEEN
MOVED UP TO MARCH.
SO THAT THAT SORT OF THE TIME
FRAME FOR COUNTIES IN
PREPARATION.
AND THEN THEY'LL DO A FULL
IMPLEMENTATION THEIR NEW SYSTEM
IN -- NOVEMBER.
TWENTY TWENTY THE OTHER TWO WERE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEIR THEIR
MOVING THROUGH THE PROCESS BUT A
WERE WORKING AT IDENTIFYING
REALLY WHAT THEIR SPECIFIC PLANS
ARE REMOVING HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO DO IT AND WHAT THE CHALLENGES
ARE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT AT LEAST TWO COUNTIES IT
MAY NOT HAVE.
CERTIFIED OR APPROVED OR ONE OF
THE TERM MAY BE.
VOTING SYSTEMS FROM MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY THAT ACCURATE.
THEY WOULD HAVE POTENTIALLY
WORST CASE NUYS TO OF THAT --
HAVEN'T TAKEN THE STEPS
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE A SYSTEM
WITH A THAT CERTIFIED IN TO THE
NEW VOTING SYSTEM STANDARDS.
IN THE PRIMARY ELECTION CORRECT
YES AND WHAT TO COUNTIES OF THE
CAN I GET BACK CENTER IN ALL OF
THE TOP OF MY HEAD I CAN'T
REMEMBER IF THIS SOUNDS LIKE A
BIG DEAL.
SO YES LET US KNOW THAT YES I
WILL ALL FOLLOW UP WITH YOU.
IT IS THIS ENOUGH TIME JUST AS
WELL AS IT IS IT ENOUGH TIME FOR
THOSE TWO COUNTIES TO GET THERE.
I THINK THERE'S A YOU KNOW
THERE'S ANY OTHER CHALLENGES
IMPLEMENTATION NO IT'S NOT LOS
ANGELES IS IT HAS BEEN MOVING
FOR WITH THEIR OPEN SOURCE
VOTING SYSTEM.
I'M IN THERE ON THE ON THE PATH
THAT TO THEIR ONE OF THE ONES
THAT HAD SUBMITTED A REQUEST FOR
EXTENSION USE AS A BACKUP.
I'M.
IT'S I THINK YES A YEAR OUT --
THERE'S CHALLENGES IN ANY
PROCUREMENT AS I SAID.
I'M AND I THINK THAT ALLOWING IT
THEY WOULDN'T BE USING
DECERTIFIED EQUIPMENT MAY BE
USING WE WOULD BE EXTENDING.
OUR APPROVAL FOR USE FOR THOSE
CAN'T THE SPECIFIC COUNTY CITY.
WHAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE PEACE?
WITH THE BACKDROP OF YEAH RIGHT.
ALSO IT IF THERE'S CHALLENGES
AND I WERE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THEM. TO TO AGAIN I DON'T BUY
THEIR ISSUES WITH THEIR PENS
POINTS ARE WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT'S
REALLY.
AM NEEDS TO HAPPEN TO TO MOVE
FORWARD.
WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO BE IN
THAT SITUATION KNOWN RIGHT OR
ANY COUNTY [inaudible]
NOW.
DOESN'T HAVE THE YOU KNOW.
THE ISSUE IS TAKEN CARE OF WELL
IN ADVANCE TO GIVE TRUST TO THE
PUBLIC AND TO THE VOTE.
HI THIS IS GENERALLY NINETY
ELECT DIVISION A SECTOR STATE
OFFICE.
AND THESE ARE TOO SMALL COUNTY I
CAN REMEMBER THE NAMES I THERE.
TWO SMALL CAN USE IT DIDN'T HAVE
THE FUNDING OF THE MONEY THAT
THEY NEEDED IN ORDER TO PURCHASE
NEW SYSTEM.
SO THIS PROPOSAL WOULD GO A LONG
WAY IN ASSISTING THEM MONEY IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO MOVE FORWARD
AND GETTING A NEW PHONE SYSTEM.
TWENTY TWENTY BUT I'LL SKIP MY
ROTARY CLUB SPEECH BUT EVEN
THOUGH IT'S ONLY TWO SMALL
COUNTIES TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE IS AN ISSUE SERVING THE
ELECTION.
OUR FOR NOVEMBER [inaudible]
TWENTY TWENTY THAT WILL
[inaudible]
A OF SOME CONCERN AMONG THE BODY.
IS TO THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTRIC SO IT.
YOU NEED TO STAY ABREAST.
YES WE TAKE THAT VERY SERIOUSLY --
WORKING WITH THESE COUNTY -- WE
HAVE -- IN EVERYTHING WE DO.
ANYTHING ELSE -- WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM JEAN HEARST HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA.
THE ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA THE COUNTY OF
INTER AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
OF THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT IN COUNTY VOTING
ELECTION SYSTEMS I JUST WANT TO
MAKE TWO QUICK POINTS I'M
DECERTIFICATION EARLIER THIS
YEAR DID PLACE A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF FINANCIAL PRESSURE ON
COUNTIES.
SO I THINK WE SEE THIS PROPOSAL
IS SORT OF ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN AND ALSO -- THE
STATE HAS VERY LITTLE FINANCIAL
PARTICIPATION IN THE OPERATIONS
OF ELECTIONS -- WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT FUNDING THE
STATE HAS PROVIDED FOR VOTING
MACHINES BUT FOR THE MOST PART
WERE -- OPERATING ELECTIONS
LOCALLY AND THOSE COSTS ARE
CONSIDERABLE SO READ ENCOURAGE
YOUR MOST POSITIVE CONSIDERATION
OF THIS REQUEST.
THANK YOU.
MISTER.
ADAM CHEN MEMBERS MONICA MILLER
REPRESENT A KIND OF ALAMEDA WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
AT THIS POINT BECAUSE WE'RE
STILL ANALYZING THE MAY REVISE.
I'LL TELL YOU WE HAD ACTUALLY
PRETTY LIKE THE CALL YESTERDAY
WITH THE SECTOR STATES OFFICE.
BECAUSE WE ARE IN DIRE NEED OF
THE FUNDS WE REPLACED OUR
EQUIPMENT WE HAD TO ELECTIONS
AND THEY HAVE DONE REALLY WELL.
WE WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THIS
CONSIDERATION AGAIN WITH
OFFICIAL POSITION BUT WE KNOW
THAT SO FAR IT'S WORKED WELL FOR
US AND FOR SEEKING TO GET OUR
REIMBURSEMENT.
BUT I THINK IT'S EITHER COUNTY
START TO ROLL THERE'S OUT YOU'RE
ABLE TO COME ONLINE WE DO A
PAYMENT PLAN WITH OUR VENDOR AND
THEY'VE BEEN VERY GENEROUS AS
WELL BUT I PAYMENT PLANS TO MEET
YOU HAVE TO PAY AND WE HAVE TO
HAVE THE FUNDS IN THE BANK. TO
PAY SO WE AGAIN ARE HOPEFUL THE
PEOPLE CONSIDER S. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY -- SO WE HAVE A MOTION WE
DO [inaudible]
WILL MOVE.
BUT I MUST OFFER ORACLE QUESTION.
IS THERE ANY AGENCY OF THE
BUDGET.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN AFFECTED
NEGATIVELY BY FISCALE.
THAT'S NOT BEFORE US TODAY BUT
IT'S GOING TO BE AGAIN.
AND I'M REALLY GETTING TIRED OF
DEALING WITH IT. THREE WAYS.
OKAY LOCAL THANK YOU CENTER.
SENATOR LEON SENATOR NIELSEN'S
COMEDY [inaudible]
THIS REPORT.
YEAH RIGHT -- SHOT.
SENATE GAZA HI SENATOR NIELSEN.
SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE STUCK WITH US BOTH AGAIN --
YES THE MOTOR VOTER OKAY. ELEVEN
NEW MOTOR VOTER COSTS GO AHEAD.
GREAT THANK YOU -- AGAINST IS A
LAPSE LEAD TO PRODUCE ACTRESS
EIGHT AND GENERALLY IN CHIEF OF
ELECTIONS FOR THE SECTOR STATES
OFFICE.
AND THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTS AT
TWO POINT. NINE MILLION DOLLARS --
TO TWENTY THREE AND IS A REQUEST
TO FROM TO THE GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME FUND FUNDING AND TO ALLOW.
SECTOR STATE CONTINUE PROVIDING
ACTOR VOTER REGISTRATION DATED
COUNTIES.
AND THIS REVOVES AROUND THE
IMPLEMENTATION NEW MOTOR VOTER
AND DMV.
WE'VE HAD TO HIRE A CONTRACTOR
TRIVIA CRACK VOTER REGISTRATION
DATA RECEIVED FROM DMV BEFORE
IT'S TRANSMITTED.
TO ADD BEFORE WE TAKE IT INTO A
STATEWIDE SYSTEM ENTRANCE INTO
THE COUNTIES WE'VE HAD -- TO
EMPLOY A A LOT OF THAT MANUAL
WORK AND WORK AROUNDS TO INSURE
THAT THE DATA IS ACCURATE BEFORE
WE SEND IT TO THE BEFORE WE PUT
IN OUR SYSTEM AND SEND IT DOWN
TO THE COUNTIES.
AND THIS PROPOSAL FUNDS WORK
FROM APRIL OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AND CONTINUE WORK THROUGH --
NINETEEN TWENTY IT'S AN
INTERMISSION BETWEEN FOR DMB THE
WORK THAT WE'VE HAD THAT WE'VE
TAKEN ON AND WITH IMPLEMENTATION
INDIAN THESE ISSUES. TO WORK TO
IMPROVE THE VOTER REGISTRATION
AND AND THE DATA TRANSMISSION
BETWEEN OUR OUR OFFICES.
THANK YOU.
HELLO NO CONCERNS BYNUM.
NO PUBLIC COMMENT.
SENATE QUICKLY WHO'S THE
CONTRACTOR.
IT'S OUR SYSTEM INTEGRATOR SO
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO ACTUALLY
BUILT OUR STATEWIDE SYSTEM IT'S
C. GI.
MADAM CHAIR.
THIS IS BEEN SUCH A SENSITIVE
AREA.
SUCH A PROBLEMATIC AREA
PROBLEMATIC AGENCY I WOULD
RECOMMEND WE PUT SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE
HERE.
UP REQUIRING AND SIX MONTHS IN A
PROGRESS REPORT ON HOW THIS IS
GOING NOT HAVE TO WAIT AROUND
ALWAYS NEXT YEAR.
AND MAYBE WE COULD TAKE SOME
INTERVENING STEPS OF SUFFICIENT
PROGRESS IS NOT BEEN ACHIEVED
THAT WOULD BE JUST SAYING PLEASE
GIVE US A UPDATED YOUR PROGRESS
[inaudible]
OKAY -- RIGHT BUT YOU CAN ADD
THE LANGUAGE TO THIS RULING.
MY WHICH CAN BE ADDED TO THE
MOTION [inaudible]
FUNDS.
YES YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH.
I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR IT'S IS
REPORTING US REPORTING ON THE
OUR WORK VERSES DMV'S REPORTING
ON YES THERE WERE EARLY ON YOU
OKAY.
NO NO AND THIS IS NOTHING
ADVERSARIAL INTENT IT'S MUCH
MUCH BIGGER NOW TELL I THOUGHT
IT WAS A TRANSFER DMV
RESPONSIBILITIES SECTORS STATE
[inaudible]
WHAT?
NO WE WILL PUT THAT ON OKAY.
WE HAVE A MOTION -- WILL CALL
PLEASE SENATOR RAZA I CENTER
NIELSEN.
SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU.
THE COMMON PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
MADAM CHAIR IT'S ON A TOPIC
THAT'S NOT IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY
THAT WILL COME UP.
MY NAME'S DAVE WALRATH I
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA RETIRED
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
WE'RE HAVING OUR CONVENTION IN
LOS ANGELES ON ONCE HE THIRTEEN
FRIDAY.
AND SO THE ISSUE WILL PROBABLY
COME UP WITH YOU ON THURSDAY.
I IT IS DEALING WITH THE USUAL
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S MAYBE VISION
PROPOSES TO CAL STARS. FOR
ASSISTING SCHOOL DISTRICT
EMPLOYERS IN MAKING THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THAT AND HOPE YOU'LL BE IN
SUPPORT OF IT AS WELL.
I APOLOGIZE FOR COMING UP ON
SOMETHING THAT WAS OUT OF ORDER
BUT I WON'T BE HERE IN TIME WHEN
IT IS IN ORDER THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YEAH SHE MAKE.
COMMENTS YES THIS WALL F. GOOD
TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO SEE YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU AND WORKING
WITH EACH OTHER A LONG TIME AND
TURN AROUND SAILOR DOCTOR
PETERSON VINE DID YOU KNOW HIM
[inaudible]
RICHEST.
YES THIS THIS WOULD BE CENTER
NIELSEN ON TWO TWO SIX TWO YEAH
I'D LIKE TO SEPARATE NUMBER TWO
OKAY SO WE'LL HAVE ALL.
TAKEN -- ON ISSUE NUMBER TWO
SENATOR SENATOR NELSON LOW
[inaudible]
AND THEN [inaudible] THREE
ISSUES THREE TO FIVE SEVEN
NIELSEN YES CENTER NOTHING
[inaudible]
YES.
WHICH ONE IS WHICH NUMBER SHE'S --
ISSUE SIX SECOND SHIFT OKAY
ISSUE SIX THE COMMISSION ON THE
STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS CENTER
NIELSEN [inaudible]
OUR GUN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES.
YOU WANT TO STAY.
YOU WANT TO SAY A LOT
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH